wir sind zurück mit einem neuen video
zum thema werben und präfix wir haben
euch schon werben mit fair und werben
mit c erfolge stellt die links findet
ihr hier unten und in diesem video geht
es um das präfix endlos geht's werben
die mit and anfangen sind keine
trennbaren werben das heißt sie werden
auch immer zusammen geschrieben in
jeglicher kommunikation und diese cent
ist auch ein ein wort was man verstehen
kann ein bisschen intuitiv im deutschen
es hat keine direkte übersetzung aber in
fast allen werben transportiert ist eine
bedeutung und diese bedeutung ist
eigentlich mit etwas aufhören oder mit
etwas stoppen etwas ja mit etwas mit
etwas aufhören wir zeigen euch jetzt mal
ein paar beispiele mit janisch unser
erstes werk ist entspannen entspannen
heißt es ist das gegenteil quasi von
spannen jannis sieht man hier er spannt
dieses band und er ist angespannt das
gegenteil ist entspannt also wenn etwas
nicht mehr gespannt ist wenn etwas nicht
mehr
anstrengend ist dann kann man entspannen
hier sehen wir jetzt sehr entspannt
entfernen wenn jemand fern ist dann ist
er weit weg und wenn sich jemand
entfernt dann geht er immer weiter weg
janisch entfernt sich von mir
unser nächstes verb ist enthüllen wenn
etwas eine hülle hat dann ist es
zugedeckt verhüllen heißt dass man etwas
zudeckt und das gegenteil davon ist
enthüllen man nimmt die hülle weg die
amish enthüllt sein gesicht entfremden
wenn sich zwei menschen fremd sind dann
kennen sie sich nicht so gut
und wenn sich jemand entfremdet dann ist
das der prozess dass man sich plötzlich
nicht mehr so gut kennt wie früher
wer bist du denn entfallen
janosch erzählt uns eine geschichte aber
verdammt ihm ist ein wichtiges wort
entfallen wenn einem etwas entfällt
heißt das dass einem etwas nicht mehr
einfällt
man kann sich nicht mehr erinnern
janisch ist das wort entfallen
entwaffnen janisch hat eine waffe wenn
ich jemanden entwaffnen das heißt dass
ich jemandem die waffe wegnehmen
entdecken
janosch guckt was unter dem tuch ist
er entdeckt eine flasche kaffee
der ist ja noch warm lecker also eine
decke ist wortwörtlich eine decke wie
ihr gesehen habt also man kann etwas
bedecken das heißt man verfüllt etwas
oder es ist eine decke über etwas und
entdecken wird dafür benutzt dass man
etwas findet oder etwas neues findet
unser nächstes web ist entlaufen der
normalzustand ist laufen janisch läuft
wenn man aber das wort entlaufen benutzt
dann heißt das dass jemand weg läuft
also für immer sich trend von einem ort
das benutzt man zum beispiel mit tieren
die aus dem zoo entlaufen
da ist schon wieder ein löwe aus dem zoo
entlaufen
jetzt könnt auch ihr weiter deutsch
lernen die deutsche grammatik ist
manchmal nervig aber manchmal kann man
ist auch ein bisschen spielerisch lernen
so zum beispiel in unserer fc klengen
dort haben wir einen gender trainer
aufgebaut denn die deutschen artikel
lernen ist manchmal recht nervig und mit
unserem sender trainer könnt ihr das wie
in einem spiel lernen probiert das mal
aus und wir werden auch in zukunft
wieder videos für euch machen auch zum
thema präfix wir freuen uns auf euch
nächste woche schaltet wieder ein bei
siemens
[Musik]